I'm Juan Cisco. Marnie.
Hi. I'm running. Running for U.S.
Congress, running in Arizona's
Sixth District,
a key race and the battle
for control of the U.S. House.
I can answer any questions for you
before you vote.
Juan Cisco.
Manny was born in Mexico,
immigrated here
to Tucson, Arizona,
with his family at age 11.
Nice to meet you.
He's also a Republican.
I'm someone that grew up here
in a very Democrat area
in the state of Arizona.
As a first generation
Hispanic Republican, so that really
puts me in a different light,
I think, of saying, well,
how do you see the issues?
I see them very uniquely
as a conservative,
especially on economy issues
he believes are driving voters this year,
all voters.
When people ask me, hey,
what are the Hispanic issues
we should be focusing on?
I kind of chuckle a little bit
and I say, well,
there are no Hispanic issues.
There are issues that impact everyone.
I'm paying the same thing for guys
milk and eggs
that the person next door is paying,
that they're not Hispanic.
Thank you all for being here.
Good.
I just bought a companion
to make that point.
He invited
local small business
owners to his campaign office
to discuss their challenges.
No traffic it's affected us a lot.
The economy.
Like when I'm young,
there are only 13 Hispanic Republicans
now serving in the House.
Cisco Marney is one of 33
Hispanic GOP candidates on the ballot
this year.
Part of a concerted leadership
effort to boost
their ranks in the chamber.
Do you feel comfortable
with the way that leaders in your party
have expressed themselves
vis-a-vis the Hispanic community?
Well, I can only control
how I express myself
with the Hispanic community.
And I
and I'm very proud of the way
that we've done it.
They argue
Democrats are taking Hispanic voters
for granted.
I think the Republican Party
is recognizing
that it's right there for the taking
if the right message is there
and the right messenger as well.
And that's where candidates like
myself come in.
Helder Toasty is doing just that.
I'm here with Bob Moss,
which is an effort to get Latinos
to actually go vote,
running a new program for Senate
Republicans called Vamos.
We walked with him through neighborhoods
in Nevada
as he searched for votes
in growing
Hispanic communities
just a few miles from the Vegas Strip.
This,
as far as I know,
has historically been pretty blue Yeah.
I mean, traditionally, Democrats
have gotten 80. 90% of the vote here.
So the reason we're here
is to get votes
where we traditionally haven't shown up.
He uses a special app,
micro-targeting potential voters.
We've loaded
in all of the different names
of the voters
that we're trying to talk to.
This particular
voters, a weak Republican,
which means they're on the team.
They don't always
show up in the general election.
Hi there.
This GOP ground
operation is in nine
states with critical Senate races
this year.
The whole point of the program
is to just talk to Hispanic voters
because when you're in a get out
the vote phase,
these voters are the ones
who get left behind.
Not like this.
I haven't decided
which party I'll go with.
Maria, Mel Goza is exactly
the kind of voter
Republicans are trying to attract by them
from a deal.
I didn't promise many things,
but I feel like he hasn't delivered
the yellow to Partido
and the other party.
I don't know much about it.
Knows not not so much there, she said.
Until now,
neither Republicans nor Democrats
actually asked for her vote.
El Primero.
Si, si.
With my broken Spanish, I got the gist.
Yeah, she's a Democrat.
Only voted Democrat,
and now she's not sure.
And now she's on the market.
Hi.
Back in Tucson, Arizona,
I'm Kirsten Hengel.
I'm running for
Congressional District six.
The Democrat
running in the crucial House
contest against Juan Sisk.
Amani
rejects the idea that her party
takes Hispanic voters for granted.
Every single voter
is important in this district.
This is a diverse district,
and I certainly will not take anybody's
vote for granted.
And thank you
for RO for making that a big word.
Well, it is a message.
Kirsten Engle argues
her GOP opponent is out of touch here
because he applauded
the reversal of Roe v Wade.
I'm there to fight on this issue
to make sure that women are respected,
that this is an issue
that they can continue
to make for themselves.
Or with their family, with their doctors,
with who they want to confide in.
Jenny, nice to meet you, Jenny.
It's an issue Sysco
Amani encountered while courting voters.
She says Republicans
don't engage with enough
or even if you don't vote for me,
which would make me really sad.
But if that happens,
I still want to talk to you
and get your thoughts and opinion
and see what you know how you see things.
Because my job as representative
will be to represent everyone,
make my
uterus my body part, to deal with
whatever I want to do with it.
If Alex de Freitas is a Latina proving
Cisco money, right.
Issues among Hispanic voters are the same
as everyone else.
I consider myself pro-life,
and with exceptions of course, so
that's where I am.
I don't think they should be your job
to tell me what I can
and can't do with my body as a female.
Sisk Amani did not win her vote,
I think only asked the logo.
But both
he and Republicans across the country
trying to engage Hispanic voters argue
the GOP mission is larger than one vote
and one race.
We show up now
and we show up these communities
while they're growing so that,
you know,
when they start voting and participating
and putting up candidates
they can say, I'm a Republican
and I'm voting for Republicans.
And and they represent
me and they show up.